سنتابع معكم هذه التقنيه نظام كريسبر
للهندسه الجينيه بزق نجمه بشكل واسع
وتقنيه كريسبيل للتعديل الجيني تتيح تعديل
الحمض النووي للكائن الحي وهي ثوره علميه
غير مسبوقه تتيح كرسبير للعلماء تعديل
الجينات من خلال مقص جيني يضاهي في عمله
برنامجا لمعالجه النصوص ويمكنها ايضا رصد
التشوهات الجينيه واستبدال عناصر اخرى في
الحمض النووي بها على كل حال كانت اول
تجربه ناجحه قد اجريت عام 2000 عندما تم
اصلاح النظام المناعي لمولود وقتها لكن
مجال التغيير الجيني زاخر بالمفاجات
المبهره خاصه ناحيه الطفرات فهناك تجارب
على ارانب معدله وراثيا لتكون اكثر نحافه
مثلا لكن اصبحت السنتها اطول من المعتاد
ومواشي تم تعديلها وراثيا لتكون بلا قرون
لكن النتيجه انه اصبح لدي حمض نووي بكتيري
يعزز مقاومه الجسم للمضادات الحيويه
[موسيقى]